all right this morning in our school
matters series how talking to middle
school students about academic pressure
and fitting in can help them do better
in school new research focused on more
than 1300 sixth graders making the
transition to middle school the study
found the students who receive social
and emotional support from their
teachers had better grades attendance
and fewer disciplinary problems
psychologist and CBS News contributor
Lisa d'amour joins us now Lisa well
basically it's about that rough first
day of school yeah study done in a large
public school district in the Midwest
where they had thirteen hundred sixth
graders and a half of them teachers gave
a very straightforward three-part
message they said the transition to
middle school is challenging you will
feel unsure about how you fit in this
will not last forever and there's
support here if you need it and to the
other half they said sort of welcome
yeah and what they found is that the
kids who got the message that they
should expect some difficulty as they
adapt they should expect some challenge
those kids over the course of the year
had fewer disciplinary incidents came to
school more often and at the end of the
year had better grades than the kids who
did not get the expect challenge message
what do you think that happens I mean
what is it about setting expectations
for kids which it's a little sad to say
look the world can be tough out there
how you might face some difficulties I
mean what is it about saying that that
makes it easier to then face those
difficulties well what's interesting is
if we consider the alternative I think
often when we sense the kids are anxious
we jump in with reassurance that's
incredibly well-meaning we say it's
gonna be amazing you look adorable
you're gonna have a great day you don't
think you're supposed to tell them look
it's not gonna go so great for you look
you don't think you are right but what
we find is when we say it's gonna be
fantastic don't worry it's gonna be
amazing what happens is they get there
and they feel tense and then they think
oh no something's really wrong but of
course they're going to feel tense
they're adapting to an entirely new
environment the other thing that can
happen is they can feel less sure that
they can come home and say it wasn't
great because you've said already it
should be fantastic so you want them to
have realistic expectations so you don't
feel like there's something wrong
absolutely and and it's interesting
worry takes up bandwidth and so when
kids are worried about being worried
they have less energy to focus on school
I like the point you made that don't
confuse conflict with bullying yes
because we are very quick very quick to
use a B word these days bully bully
bully you said don't confuse it - what
is the difference so for me
conflict is like the common cold of
human interaction if you're going to be
with other people you will have
conflicts and you will get cold yes
and bullying is more like pneumonia so
conflict is two people not getting along
bullying when we define it very
carefully as we do in psychology it's
when one person is being systematically
targeted and cannot defend themselves so
that is dangerous it needs to be treated
there needs to be real intervention for
conflict we can help kids manage
conflict more effectively but we want to
make the distinction in between is my
child
you know tangling with another child
versus is my child being attacked and
unable to defend themselves is the
recommendation just walk away or do you
give the kids I mean this is a real
question in my household I have a rising
5th grader and I remember he was coming
into 4th grade III remember fourth grade
and I said look you may on the
playground face some kids who do X Y & Z
here are just some things you might say
back that could get you out of the
situation and basically put junior
versions of put downs to deflect and get
away what we find is if the kids can
kind of laugh off an attack it does
deflate it and what happens is it goes
from being bullying to conflict because
your child is successfully defending
themselves well we also see across the
board when we look at bullying is that
the most effective interventions come
from bystanders the kids who are
standing around when it happens actually
have the most power to stop it they can
say hey knock it off or come play with
us or they can get a teacher so I think
if we're concerned about bullying we can
say to kids on the way into school
you're not to mistreat anyone and if you
see someone being mistreated you are to
step in or you are to invite them love
that regulation you are to go get an
adult you have to do something
well my go-to was always if somebody
said something so really not too much
you can go after that so those yourface
officers very mature thank you very much
Lisa